so it goes to home video how long before
then you get your next job which is the
wedding sing so meanwhile Adam was
having his career was going in a really
good way and I was determined not to
come to LA without a movie because I
knew everybody was a director and and
Adam had seen the movie and loved it and
I remember he had his agent see it and
they're like I was cool you know and the
fact that they did a movie got him
couldn't wait for me to direct his
movies he had done I think Billy mess
and by then he called me up and said I'm
working on a comedy album he already
made a movie come to LA come for two
weeks and help me with the comedy album
and it was an album called what the hell
happened to me so I wrote on a bunch of
skits I acted on some of them and then I
did a music video for one of the songs
it was Steve polychron appleís it's kind
of a precursor to the wedding singer cuz
it was a 80s bully but it was all about
80s wardrobe stone wash pants and and
the bi-level haircut and I shot this
video and I didn't realize like all eyes
because Adam was just starting to really
excel every bigwig in town came to see
who's this Frank Karachi God direct in
the video and I'm just loving it cuz I'm
getting like real equipment you know and
and it had like all the comedian's that
were friends with David Spade
Rob Schneider so many interesting cameos
it was like David Arquette Garry
Shandling was in it so it's this really
fun crazy silly video and then I on the
album we did a 23 city tour the album
went double platinum it was like one of
the biggest Sandler album so it was a
good little run where I literally came
for two weeks and that a bag of clothes
for two weeks and I didn't stop working
I got an editing system in our house you
know we had the house and Beverly Hills
and I was like editing all the videos
myself I'm like this is great like film
school again I'm like this has got me
20:28 something like that and I'm like I
can't believe I'm getting to like live
with my friends shoot stuff people
really seeing it edit I'm like this is a
dream come true
and then we did the 23 city tour like it
was a rock and roll tour with a bunch of
Adams comedy songs so like the Hanukkah
song he did a bunch of other songs like
the Halloween song piece-of-shit car a
lot of the ones you know though like the
turkey song for Thanksgiving and I did
sort of very inexpensive I came up with
the stage designer was an outdoor
drive-in movie in the summer and it was
like beach balls and all this stuff and
and and I had the set designer from his
movies do the sadness and I had a screen
and on the screen I would do things like
there was a song about grandmother's so
I got a bunch of grandmother's shot him
on green screen dancing with spatulas
and then I took like contact paper from
like you know like Grandma contact paper
that you'd put in the kitchen oh yeah
like really corny powdery and I've
green-screen them again I just think it
was like this weird it would be inspired
by like a Pink Floyd drug video but it
was just silly comedy for stoners and
then the other thing is we had a skit
that like it was a super stoner skins
available there was a talking goat and
the talking goat these for stoners come
across his talking goat and Ben eyes
tied to the back of the truck and
they're like oh she's talking go and
Adams divorces ago like hey hey guys
that was your timey I'm kind of bored
here and I played the old man who used
to beat the goat and and and so that
skit was just the most popular one and
that's like all I had a filmer goat for
the concert because the kids loved it
and I say kids are like 20 year olds and
were 30 at the time and so the goat
opens up this show and people go nuts
and then I bring him back a few times
and new line had seen the show and they
were like we want to do a talking goat
movie and and we're like oh that's cool
but like we were thinking of doing
another movie though and then we pitched
them I wanted to do a movie that was an
80s movie and Adam and Tim had to come
up an idea for a wedding singer who gets
jilted and has to eat perform weddings
after he has his heart broken
and I said that let's make that ATS
because then you can sing songs I won't
look like you're trying to be cool it'll
be a little retro it'll take the curse
off and they said great and then we
pitched that and it's funny because it
was 1995-96 we're pitching an 80s movie
and people like 80s that was six years
ago and I'm gonna trust me like we test
different like I had the same clothes
from six years ago like trust me no no
and then like sure enough I made I
learned my first miss my first thing not
to do in Hollywood
well that's pitching the producer I go
think of how in Dazed and Confused the
70s was a personality and then they
produce it was like hazing confused made
like ten million dollars why would you
reference that movie and I'm like no no
just how cool it was and I'm like oh I
get it you just gotta move when you want
to get money you have the reference it
didn't translate I was like no it's how
cool oh yeah it's like the Titanic nod
that was that yeah so anyway so we
pitched that and they loved the idea and
then we had we kind of worked on the
script and then Carrie Fisher new line
hired her this spend time on the script
because she was such the the script
doctor for romantic movies and I got to
spend just got to LA you know what my
gym bag I'd only been there for a few
months and next thing you know I'm at
Carrie Fisher's house I'd have to go
over a house every day when she was
writing she would literally lay in bed
and write she would watch TV she's like
let's watch old movies and then I'd
literally be laying a better carry
fishing I can't believe I'm in bed with
Princess Leia not you right just so
working not nothing and and yeah we
watched these old movies and she showed
me all these great oh oh you know
romantic comedies Roman Holiday like you
name him breastfeed Breakfast at
Tiffany's and then we would write and
and it was great and we got to make this
amazing story and and then drew Saigon
and
before you know it I'm like Austin I'm
like wow I came I still have not gone
home I still have this bag of clothes
and I'm directing the wedding singer in
that and I remember the first day
pulling up on sunset the house we shot
was with the old lady with the meatballs
Rosie and it's first time driving the
set right I'm driving my will rental
Honda Civic and I'm like why are these
trucks here I'm like I'm used to making
a student phone we had one truck there
was like truck after truck and it's a
low-budget movie is like a 10 million
dollar movie I was so intimidated by the
time I walked to said that there was all
this equipment I'm like I need some
dolly track in the camera I didn't know
you need all this and then yeah but I
jumped right in and and I just did what
I knew how to do and I realize oh now I
have a lot of crew when you change
things that just happens fast and yeah
and when we made that movie we had no
idea it was gonna hit like it was a
little low budget movie and I just blew
up in a whole different way and then I
thought now I'm [ __ ] because now I
can't make all those little weird movies
why because you thought now you're gonna
be pigeonholed yeah yeah and then
actually the finding was we I was like
come on we're on a roll let's do the
waterboy so the wedding singer didn't
even open we made the waterboy and so in
the middle of doing the waterboy the
wedding singer opened we flew home for
the premiere and it was like wow it was
great knowing now there's no pressure on
the waterboy like they gave us more
money in time we didn't feel like you
know when you making a movie of a gun to
your head with budget and yeah
but I did find it for a long time I was
pigeon-holed I had so many little movies
I wanted to do and I'd be willing to do
it for no money and it was once they put
you in that box in Hollywood it's hard
to and I didn't know enough about how
the business works to figure out how to
make the little movie Lily took me ten
movies till I got to make another little
indie you know and I along I didn't want
to you know and the movie I just made
know how they're ticking like seven
years to get that together the little
ones are really hard to get going just
cuz you know it's always talent driven
you know so you have to find a piece
they want to do it how did you get
clearance for all of the songs in the
wedding scene the wedding it well
platinum soundtrack by the way and they
were really easy because most of them
were one-hit wonders so they cost you
know I don't you know what loop the song
is close but they would cost like five
grand
there is Jersey greatest blonde joke
Bruce Bruce oh okay so the Bruce
Springsteen song you know and like
250,000 for that song oh wow I mean when
you when you go for the classics right
there 250 but all like things like white
wedding and and especially some of the
ones you haven't heard since then they
were one hit with even more one-hit
wonders yeah they're like $5,000 a song
which relatively cheap at the time so
yeah it was a really lucrative
soundtrack for I didn't have a piece of
that it was my first movie but I have a
platinum record on my wall so cool did
you all work together in terms of what
songs you really like like video killed
the radio star yeah you know um I was an
80s new wave kid so I had all the music
the Adam had his you know we both grew
up on the same music it's funny he went
a little more I went more edgy and he
went a little more commercial and we did
the one thing where you all often battle
on his music and then in hindsight I
look back I'm like it's a perfect
balance that if it was all me it would
go to edgy and if it was all him you
know like so like the song that I
remember there was a hollow note song
and I was like I want haircut 100 that
was more 80s and and you know now when I
watch it people love all annoyed song so
but like the Cure all that stuff this is
that was me I was like new wave guide
like blond hair shaved I was that kid so
I was like yeah yeah yeah no Suzy song
in there no no no and we wanted Prince
to open with 1999 but he wouldn't give
any rights away and also when doves cry
was supposed to be in the in the club
scene but David Bowie said yes to China
girl which was a real men scream yeah
was people either I mean Prince David
Bowie win-win not of this earth
yeah they're like beyond yeah okay miss
both of them yes
you